[Applause]
let's go Joe the chant he wanted to hear
on the day he said he wanted to do it
all over again
the audience the men and women of
America's building industry the blue
collar workers from around the country
the beneficiaries of President Biden's
legislative achievements over the past
four years I signed the bipartisan
infrastructure law because they have the
strongest economy in the world we need
the best infrastructure in the world
standing ovations then over and over
this is just the audience that Joe Biden
wanted
I'm happy that he's running again it's
better than that orange thing
I would like to see him change Vice
Presidents
you know doesn't look like he will wow
probably won't but that won't stop me
from supporting him
you're not worried about his age
it's always a concern but uh he's a sage
you know he's a he's a wise old man
absolutely Freedom the announcement
dropped online Before Dawn in Washington
an echo of his pitch for the presidency
exactly four years ago I know we're good
and decent people softly spoke I know
we're still a country that believes in
honesty and respect
a contrast team Biden hopes to the Brash
shouting from the trumpian right
it's the same team Biden Harris because
it's almost certainly the same opponent
who was quick with his response we will
defeat Joe Biden in 2024 we will rescue
our economy we will crush inflation we
will stop The Invasion on our Southern
border we will restore our nation's
dignity and we will prevent World War
III from happening together we will all
make America great again Johnstown
Pennsylvania out of the Washington
bubble Trump's words still echo
it is one of so many parts of America
that swung to Trump
and here in this steel town no more we
found not much love for Biden I feel
he's destroying America I just think we
need fresh blood on both sides of the
aisle so what do I think of him I don't
know if he knows he
Across America there is a collective
groan it is the same old divides the
same old challenges and the same old men
Mark Stone Sky News in Washington